hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell and we are
bringing you the et interview the first
pretty late oh my goodness okay my baby
is five months old and I feel like it
mrs. Rheiner
so you poor thing had so much postpartum
after yeah you had a buddy and this time
you were telling me you came home in the
first day you pried and tie how did you
react
okay that's a smart man where are you
scared that you would happen this time
yes because they say that your chances
of getting it again are higher when
you've had it the first time and so it
was always in the back of my mind and I
went with such a full time in my life
and I was so stubborn about it and it
lasted so long but I mean I knew
instantly when I had him that it was a
different experience bouncing back
body-wise because you look incredible so
you and I were talking about you gained
less weight this time around during your
pregnancy than the first time so compare
and contrast a little bit my first
pregnancy I gained a good 50 pounds a
lot of it was water a lot of it was that
first pregnancy
you know indulgence this time I gained
about half of that and I felt like I
looked more all baby this time around
but I didn't work out this time so it's
really weird and unfortunately you have
to credit a lot to genetics given your
public bachelor experience and dating on
television how are you gonna be with
them when they're older and they're kind
of getting into the waiting into the
dating waters given your experience all
I can do with them is just be honest I
mean I was a hot mess when it came to
dating and there is no I mean no denying
that I wish growing up my parents had
kind of shipped me a little bit and said
what are you doing you know you're
strong you're independent you're your
own person and I want them to be better
than I was especially my daughter you
know when I look at how I was from like
20 to 25 I want her to be so much better
than the person I was you know and I
didn't just date and have fun being
single
and 22 and now I'm like why didn't I
have fun being single in tweets you were
more serious more focus more I was so I
need my job I need this I need my house
I need my 2.5 kids and now being 31 I'm
like I could've enjoyed that time a
little more now ironically yeah the
bumpy road that I took um got me to
where I always wanted to be you know and
it took some weird turns and I still
look at myself going how did it end up
here
like I have married the man of my dreams
I have this career that I couldn't even
dreamed up I have two beautiful children
and it's kind of like I keep waiting for
somebody to pinch me and go as just
kidding cuz it's just it seems too good
to be true I'm a lucky girl and I know
that